mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos team viel verdienten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir finden die idee gerade neu wer was
könnte
leider haben die hat die filmhochschule
gesagt hallo wir nehmen keine leuchte
mit behinderung
fortsetzung keine blauen zelt
während in beijing die paralympics im
gang sind zeigen wir ihnen künstlerinnen
und künstler mit behinderungen die sich
nicht mehr ausbremsen lassen
[Musik]
heute machen wir station im meret
oppenheim hochhaus in basel hier ist die
saf kultur zu hause und damit auch der
kulturplatz willkommen also an jenem ort
für unsere redaktion debattiert
recherchiert und jede woche entscheidet
welchem thema wir uns widmen
[Musik]
diese woche fragen wir welche chancen
haben kunstschaffenden mit einer
beeinträchtigung oder anders gefragt wie
inclusive ist die kulturszene
[Musik]
in der schweiz leben rund 1,7 millionen
menschen mit behinderungen so die
offizielle bezeichnung
weltweit sind es über eine milliarde
wenn ich darüber nachdenke wie viele von
ihnen mit einem sichtbaren handicap habe
ich schon einmal auf einer leinwand oder
auf einer theaterbühne gesehen dann ist
die bilanz sehr mager dabei wollen doch
theater und film das wahre das ganze
leben abbilden um damit auch alle
menschen das gelingt in der
neuverfilmung des klassikers surono de
bergerac besetzt mit hollywood größe
peter den
klitschko
frano ein freak
aufgrund seiner körpergröße von einem
meter 35
in der filmischen neuinterpretation des
romantischen dramas fällt das
bekannteste attribut die
überdimensionierte nase weg man könnte
sich so besser mit cyrano identifizieren
findet schauspieler peter dinkel
was bleibt ist dieses universelle gefühl
nicht gut genug für die liebe zu sein
oder nicht zurück geliebt zu werden
dieses gefühl kennen alle egal wie sie
aussehen
peter dinkel ist einer der wenigen
bekannten schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler die nicht der gängigen norm
entsprechen
laut weltgesundheitsorganisation haben
15 prozent der weltbevölkerung
irgendeine form von behinderung
bei rund 6500 neu produzierten
kinofilmen pro jahr müssten menschen mit
behinderungen zweifelsohne besser
vertreten sein
wolfgang janssen setzt sich für mehr
gleichberechtigung in film und fernsehen
ein in berlin betreibt er seit sieben
jahren die plattform rollen etwas
vergleichbares in der schweiz
fehlanzeige er nimmt ausschließlich
schauspielende mit behinderungen unter
vertrag fördert begleitet vermittelt sie
ihr potenzial werde noch immer
vollkommen unterschätzt
man muss nicht immer reduziert sein auf
die beeinträchtigung sondern es gibt
wirklich schauspielende mit einer
behinderung die einfach geil und toll
sind und die uns was neues erzählen im
moment ist es so dass caster und
casterin uns anrufen und sehr explizit
auf die beeinträchtigung oder die
behinderung abzielen also die wünschen
sich ich kriegen anruf 18 jahre
down-syndrom
migrationshintergrund hast du das
bereits 1932 kritisierte regisseur tod
browning die stigmatisierung betroffen
in freaks zeigt er menschen mit
behinderungen als individuen mit
persönlichkeit
außergewöhnlich zu einer zeit in der
diese in kuriositäten kabinetten
vorgeführt wurden doch das kinopublikum
verließ reihenweise die seele
bietet den clip setzt sich dafür ein
berührungsangst und vorurteile abzubauen
er kritisiert beispielsweise disney für
die geplante realverfilmung von
schneewittchen und die sieben zwerge die
negative klischees befeuern würde disney
versprach nun kleinwüchsige menschen
beratend bei zu ziehen
viele filmstudios haben wenig gespür für
die thematik kommt in einem drehbuch
jemand mit einer behinderung vor wird
die figur noch heute oft von menschen
ohne behinderungen verkörpert clipping
ab wird das genannt wie in everything
mit eddie redmayne als stephen hawking
viele kritisieren das clipping ab
[Musik]
lucy wilke ist bei rollen kam unter
vertrag und bewegt sich wegen einer
genetischen veranlagung im rollstuhl
fort sie differenziert
wenn es wieder irgendwelche klischees
bedient und irgendwelche
komischen
bilder die sich da gesellschaftlich
eingeprägt haben so was wieder zu geben
ärgert mich natürlich schon wenn sich
aber jemand wirklich beschäftigt mit der
rolle dann finde ich das auch in ordnung
was ich nicht in ordnung finde ist wenn
alle rollen die menschen behinderungen
darstellen dann nur von nichtbehinderten
gespielt werden
als grund für die besetzung von
darstellenden ohne behinderungen wird
oft die zu große belastung während der
langen drehtage genannt
diese könne man menschen mit
behinderungen nicht zumuten
man muss individuell schauen ob mit
demjenigen oder mit derjenigen das
möglich ist was die produktion möchte
und das muss man eben besprechen es gibt
anstrengungen die inklusion im film und
das bewusstsein dafür zu stärken mit
quoten oder checklisten zur diversität
in der schweiz wird gerade eine solche
ausgearbeitet in anderen ländern wie den
usa ist man einen schritt weiter
dass menschen mit behinderungen sehr
wohl auch figuren spielen können bei
denen die behinderung nicht zentral ist
dafür gibt es immer mehr beispiele
die gehörlose us-amerikanerin lauren
wird live spielt im actionfilm eternus
eine superheldin
schauspieler george benson ist
tetraplegiker in der britischen serie
sex and location übernimmt er eine
wichtige nebenrolle samt sexszene
das gab es im film bislang nur selten
[Musik]
oder eben peter den clip als poetischer
held cyrano der anfang sei gemacht ist
er überzeugt aber es gebe noch viel zu
tun
wir erfinden gerade neu wer was tun kann
wir müssen diese mauer durchbrechen die
uns limitiert
wer hat die regel aufgestellt dass alle
hauptrollen liebhaber in film und
fernsehen klassisch gut aussehen müssen
firmen
auch lucy wilke richtet einen appell an
drehbuchautorinnen und produzenten es
ärgert mich wirklich wenn in filmen die
menschen mit behinderung immer am
schluss entweder sterben oder wieder
gesund sind aber es ist nie ordnung dass
sie einfach mal da sind und sich mit
etwas ganz anderem beschäftigen und
zufällig auch behindert sind das gibt es
wirklich selten
aufgewachsen ist die schauspielerin
sängerin und regisseurin lucy wilke in
einem künstler umfeld auf einem
wohnwagen platz in münchen
[Musik]
die mutter flamenco gitarrist in der
vater bildender künstler
für wilke ist früh klar sie will
schauspielerin werden auch der wunsch
filme zu machen regie zu führen regt
sich
nach gesangsunterricht und einer bühne
ausbildung für jugendliche bewirbt sie
sich an der münchner hochschule für
fernsehen und film zwei mal zwei mal
schafft sie es bis in die endrunde
zweimal wird sie abgelegt
eine assistentin hat mich angerufen und
hat dann gesagt ich wollte ihnen nur
sagen dass sie nicht genommen wurden hat
nichts mit der qualität ihrer bewerbung
zu tun hab ich gesagt ja wird mit was
dann und dann sagte sie das kann sie mir
nicht sagen
dann meinte ich okay dann kann ich es
mir an fünf fingern abzählen hat sie
gesagt ja
[Musik]
man fühlt sich hilflos wenn man so
verwende läuft und wenn man sich mühe
gibt so viel man will und es einfach
nichts nützt ich war sehr frustriert zu
dieser zeit auch
[Musik]
diskriminierung vorurteile
schicksalsschläge wilke musste wege
finden damit umzugehen
zusammen mit ihrer erblindeten mutter
gründete sie die band blind und längen
blind und lahm es war im ersten moment
eigentlich ein scherz aber wir wollten
im prinzip ist einfach mal auf den tisch
bringen und ansprechen so dass man sich
nachher auf die musik konzentrieren kann
[Musik]
selbstironie und kampfgeist haben sich
ausbezahlt seit 2020 ist willkür sondern
mitglied der renommierten münchner
kammerspiele
sechs schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
mit körperlicher oder kognitiver
beeinträchtigung hat intendantin barbara
mundel fest integriert die erste
direktorin des hauses probt das
stadttheater der zukunft
unterstützt wird sie unter anderem von
dramaturgin und haus regisseurin neele
janke langjährige mitarbeiterin und mit
leiterin des bekannten theater hora in
zürich
nach münchen hat sie einen großen
erfahrungsschatz mitgebracht und horas
etwa julia häusermann die als gäste
engagiert sind
[Musik]
mich hat das in bezug auf theater schon
immer interessiert die frage
wie schafft man es überhaupt sowohl auf
der bühne die bühne zu öffnen als auch
natürlich für die zuschauer klar zu
machen dass wir alle meinen und nicht
nur eine bestimmte schicht und dann war
das ein kleiner schritt zu sagen lädst
du ich wir sind sonst nicht glaubwürdig
intern bedeutet der schritt theater und
zusammenarbeit ganz neu denken wie hier
im stück touch
anpassungen in kauf nehmen auf und
hinter der bühne beim bau bei der
planung
ein aufwendiges unterfangen
wie wirkt sich mundls entscheidungen
finanziell aus
wie man menschen supporten muss aber
es kostet vor allen dingen
aufmerksamkeit und und
lernbereitschaft und wie kreativität
kurzum die gewohnte stadttheater
maschinerie braucht eine
generalüberholung viel
ausprobieren aber sicher waren so fragen
wie lange sind die progen vielleicht
gibt es für
ermüdungserscheinungen es gibt auch das
thema überforderung
von
spielern gegenseitig mit und ohne
behinderung beeinträchtigung
herausforderung
und dann der lernprozess wie muss man
vermitteln wie muss man begleiten und
ich glaube wichtig ist irgendwas die
kolleginnen ohne beeinträchtigungen
nicht das gefühl haben sie müssten ihre
bedürfnisse komplett zurück stellen
sondern dass wir eigentlich versuchen
also einfach zu sagen wir sind alles
künstler und künstlerinnen mit
unterschiedlichen bedürfnissen wie
schaffen wir einen gemeinsamen raum oder
zugänglichkeit von bühnenbildern zum
beispiel da bin ich kalt erwischt worden
oder dass man auf einmal eine drehbühne
eine stufe hand aber das war auch so ein
lernprozess im letzten jahr aber ist
toll weil er kommt jetzt viel wissen in
die institution oder einiges wissen
zumindestens bei der uraufführung am
wochenende sind nun erstmals vier
darstellende mit beeinträchtigungen mit
von der partie
wie sich die neuausrichtung aufs
publikum auswirkt könne man wegen corona
noch nicht sagen
einen bravourösen erfolg erzielten auf
jeden fall los sie wilke und pavillons
mit ihrem projekt das einfühlsam vom
anderssein erzählt der theaterpreis der
faust und die einladung zum berliner
theatertreffen waren ihnen sicher
[Musik]
ein hübsches gesicht aber
eine demütigung die wilke an den
kammerspielen nicht hören musste aber
verletzungen wenn auch nicht
beabsichtigt gebe es auch hier es wächst
so zusammen langsam manche leute haben
auch berührungsängste was ja auch total
okay ist und das muss man dann eben mit
der zeit abbauen
es braucht zeit
[Musik]
die münchner kammerspiele stellen sich
also der herausforderung inklusion ohne
wenn und aber wie wir gesehen haben ein
vergleichbares engagement ist in der
schweiz leider noch nicht zu finden aber
für zuschauerinnen und zuschauer mit
handicap wurde immerhin hierzulande
schon einiges getan zb barrierefreiheit
vorstellungen mit audiodeskription oder
auch gebärdensprache da ist vieles im
tun was bei unseren recherchen
aufgefallen ist in der freien szene ist
bereits viel in bewegung geraten
insbesondere auch beim tanz
in bern treffen wir cornelia jung gut
die 47 jährige ist auf dem weg zur grube
zum ersten mal wirkt sie bei einer
professionellen tanz produktion mit
eine herkulesaufgabe denn junge wurde
mit der glasknochenkrankheit geboren
schon als baby und als kind erleidet sie
immer wieder knochenbrüche junko nutzt
jede möglichkeit reist um die welt bis
sich ihr gesundheitszustand mitte ende
20 rapide verschlechtert
auf der suche nach einem ausgleich zu
all den therapien trifft sie auf den
verein beweggrund
[Musik]
der kenntnis gewohntes domini
bewegungsfreiheit nicht nur zonen zurück
geht und dass ich den fans als sie von
europa von oni auch eine lehre keinen
weg eine mannschaftssportart mache ich
bin
mitglied von einer anfang und so wenig
71 das hat natürlich sehr viel selbst zu
tun
seither hat longo in diversen
produktionen mitgewirkt
sie hilft den der administration mit und
als chorleiterin bei workshops
gegründet wurde bewegte und 1998 von der
tänzerin und choreografin susanne
schneider eine schweizer pionierleistung
die idee dazu hatte sie während ihrer
ausbildung in london
perfektion
wirklich packt sie an wandhaken
bewegt und hat eine performance gruppe
aufgebaut aber
auch eine professionelle company
der verein organisiert alle zwei jahre
ein inklusives festival und bietet
workshops an ob auf oder hinter der
bühne stets arbeiten menschen mit und
ohne behinderungen zusammen
das ist
politisches statement sondern notwendig
rät usa aber hat dann haben nicht
unbedingt
[Musik]
für cornelia jung war bewegt und und die
damit gewonnene tanz und bühnenerfahrung
sogar ein sprungbrett
denn beim letzten projekt wurde die
choreografin vanessa cook auf sie
aufmerksam und engagierte junge für ihre
neue produktion ran also tanzt tango nun
außerhalb von beweggrund mit profis
und
es macht riesenspaß
ausgeschrieben mutiger wurde und der
zunahme in der gruppe ist es so schön
anzieht wird durch den konter und das
gespürt
szenenwechsel
eine art kondom zu bewegte und im tessin
ist dass derart rasant agile seit 2010
unter der leitung von imamen rosenberg
der sich an verschiedenen fronten für
inklusion einsetzt
auch in seiner company heißt es learning
by doing
denn eine staatlich anerkannte bühnen
ausbildung gibt es für menschen mit
behinderungen in der schweiz nicht
sprich tanz bleibt hobby und das hat
auch gravierende auswirkungen auf alle
produktionen
das hat einfach damit zu tun und das ist
das privileg einer ausbildung man widmet
sich diese drei vier jahre die die
ausbildung dauert einfach täglich und
den ganzen tag über diesen beruf und
diesem handwerk und das ist eben bei uns
anders wir funktionieren
produktionsweise also von projekt zu
projekt das heißt wir müssen das auf die
freizeit oft setzen also schieben werden
die leute frei sind von ihren
werkstätten von ihren anderen berufen
das heißt man arbeitet eben späten
nachmittags abends oder am wochenende
oder auch in den ferien keine ausbildung
aber eine erste weiterbildung mit
hochschuldiplom abschluss bietet seit
letztem jahr die academia dimitri an
hopp dozent emanuel rosenberg diversität
und inklusion in der performative kunst
so der titel gearbeitet wird über
eineinhalb jahre in blöcken
studierende und lehrende eine
gemeinschaft von menschen mit und ohne
behinderung
es geht darum dass man lernt ein
inklusives projekt von a bis z wirklich
zu planen zu kreieren und zu auch
nachher auch wirklich
ausführen zu können und das zu
vermarkten also wirklich zu verkaufen
dieser studiengang führt ein
forschungsprojekt weiter dass bis 2019
an der zürcher hochschule der künste
durchgeführt wurde und auch in der zhdk
hat das projekt spuren hinterlassen das
ist eine studentin und dass es miriam
die oft mit uns arbeitet alle zwei jahre
erarbeiten bachelor-studierende nun
gemeinsam mit bühnen erfahrenen
performance mit behinderungen ein stück
das zur aufführung gelangt
[Musik]
aber es ist schon fast mehr für die
studierenden die werden das mitnehmen
als erfahrung und werden das vielleicht
anwenden können die werden aber freuen
einfach keine angst davor haben falls es
mal passiert dass sie mit menschen mit
diversität arbeiten müssen keine scheu
und keine angst mehr haben weil es schon
erlebt haben nachdem rosenberg das
projekt 2009/10 leitete konnte letztes
jahr die international bekannte
künstlerin nhl gewonnen werden
die us amerikanische tänzerin und
choreografin wurde mit nur einem teil
ihres linken arms geboren und trägt eine
prothese sie konnte an der university of
minnesota
zeitgenössischen tanz studieren
ich glaube ich war die einzige oder die
erste person in dieser studium mit
dieser besonderen körperlichkeit
ich war schon als kind daran gewöhnt die
einzige von etwas zu sein das
studium öffnet türen henry wird gleich
von der can do to dance company in
england engagiert einer der weltweit
führenden gruppen die zeigt dass tanz
keine grenzen kennt
[Musik]
jetzt entwickelt henry für das schweizer
tanzfestival steps das ende april
startet ein stück zum thema utopie
zusammen mit ihrer kollegin layla weit
die als kind an polio erkrankte und dem
erblindeten tänzer giuseppe kommunion
wir haben unterschiedliche körperlich
keiten unterschiedliche arten uns zu
bewegen wir kommen aus verschiedenen
ländern sprechen verschiedene sprachen
die frage rund um eine zukunftsvision
hat mit uns zu tun was haben wir
gemeinsam mit all unseren unterschieden
und wie begegnen wir uns obwohl wir in
einer fantastischen weise so
unterschiedlich sind
teil unseres wunsches ist es neu zu
definieren wie menschen und sehen denn
ich denke die leute gehen davon aus dass
eine behinderung nur schlecht sein kann
es kann nur schwierig oder traumatisch
sein
problematische dinge kommen von außen
mein körper ist nicht das problem mein
körper hat so viele möglichkeiten neues
zu entdecken neue wege zu kreieren um
sachen zu machen
und das sehe ich auch bei anderen
kunstschaffenden mit behinderungen
das ist sehr utopisch neue wege zu
finden auf der welt zu sein
drei tanzprofis divisionen und dank
ihrer unterschiedlichen körperlichkeit
in eine neue sprache kreieren
[Musik]
eine neue art zu kommunizieren hat auch
das künstler duo julia und christian f
geschaffen er ist mit einer spina bifida
einem offenen rücken geboren worden wie
der volksmund sagt und geht an krücken
sie ist fast gehörlos
mit ihrem gemeinsamen projekt still laut
sind sie in der freien szene unterwegs
neff spielt geige leider improvisiert
dazu mit den ohren sehen und den augen
hören sozusagen
[Musik]
mein kind nicht
christian neff unterrichtet an der
musikschule konservatorium zügig seine
ambitionen konnte er ungehindert
verfolgen wenn ich
wetten nicht triff liegt das nicht traut
sich das betrachtung hauses liegt da sie
schlicht und einfach war
juliana hingegen kämpft immer wieder
gegen berührungsängste vor ort teile mit
hörgerät hört sie gerade einmal zehn
prozent
seit 2012 gibt sie führungen für hör
beeinträchtigte in museen zudem arbeitet
sie als grafikerin
fotografenpaar formel 1 engagiert sich
unermüdlich
[Musik]
frau
therapie kommt
helm
kombinieren
und käpt n a
kim tun
christian f 's motto lautet nicht fragen
geht das sondern warum eigentlich nicht
sein credo ein dialog auf augenhöhe
der ganze debatten damit auch wünschte
konstruktiv an der sache schafft dass
man darauf
dass das ganze nicht todernst die
veranstalter bis bissig tages
kreativität sei gefragt und dafür gäbe
es in der freien szene einfach mehr raum
überhaupt es bewege sich etwas wenn noch
langsam
und irgendein
[Musik]
club
und irgendein
akzeptiert
[Musik]
und
anpassung klein
[Musik]
es geht also für uns alle und toleranz
um akzeptanz und vor allem um mut und
wenn wir diesen mut aufbringen werden
wir im besten fall belohnt von einer
welt die größer sein darf bunter und die
uns alle inspiriert nächste woche da
schauen wir auf die frauen in der kunst
wie sie übersehen wurden und nun wieder
ändern werden und gleich folgt ihr auf
sf1 die sternstunde philosophie mit
einem blick auf den ukrainer konflikt
kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]